[Applauso]
io ho paura del vuoto da piccolo ha
avuto un piccolo incidente e avevo circa
dieci anni non ha avuto nessuna
conseguenza fisica
fortunatamente però da allora sono
letteralmente terrorizzata dalle
sensazioni che si provano quando siamo
in presenza del vuoto e qualche anno fa
ero a parigi per lavoro e il mio socio
mi propone di prenderci qualche ora di
svago per vedere almeno un pochino della
città così siamo finiti sulla tour
eiffel
saliamo con l'ascensore e io resto
paralizzata non ho visto assolutamente
nulla di parigi perché non sono riuscito
a fare quei tre quattro passi che mi
avrebbero portata fino al bordo da dove
si poteva godere della vista
continuavo a ripetermi
io ho paura del vuoto
qualche anno più tardi però iniziato a
farmi una domanda ho iniziato a
chiedermi e se invece potesse arrivare
fino al bordo e se invece la realtà
fosse diversa così con l'aiuto di un
amico ho iniziato ad arrampicare la
paura ovviamente non è mai passata però
nel tempo quello che è cambiato è stata
la mia percezione rispetto a quella
paura
il mio atteggiamento ho imparato che
esistono di fronte a me tante diverse
possibili realtà il primo passo è
immaginarle
e come quando troviamo di fronte a noi
un immagine come questa qualcuno di noi
vede un coniglio qualcun altro però
magari invece vede una papera
a un certo punto capiamo che le orecchie
del coniglio sono anche il becco della
papera e un certo punto sembra quindi
che quel coniglio si trasformi in papera
e viceversa
in realtà però l'immagine è rimasta
sempre la stessa
quello che è cambiato è stata la nostra
percezione della realtà di
quell'immagine
il primo passo dicevo è immaginare
quindi perché quando io ero a parigi non
ero stata capace di vedere di fronte a
me queste diverse possibilità non ero
stato capace neanche di immaginare di
poter compiere quei tre quattro passi in
più verso il bordeaux e il punto è che
nessuno di noi
realizza una realtà un futuro che non è
neanche in grado di immaginare e questo
meccanismo funziona sia a livello
individuale sia a livello collettivo
io sono un'imprenditrice da circa 13
anni
quello che amo di più del mio lavoro è
la possibilità di avere una visione di
un futuro diverso dal presente visione
che però posso condividere con altri
trasformarla insieme in un piano in
obiettivi da raggiungere e soprattutto
insieme iniziare ad agire verso quella
direzione e piano piano quello che prima
era solo nella nostra immaginazione si
trasforma in una realtà attuale e quello
più che è più importante il fatto di
averlo fatto insieme perché non c'è
niente di meglio di un futuro che sia
costruito con l'aiuto di tutti
pensiamo ad esempio agli obiettivi per
lo sviluppo sostenibile
io potrei anche da sola provare a
immaginarmi un mondo meraviglioso dove
abbiamo superato la povertà la fame dove
l'istruzione di qualità e per tutti
l'acqua è una risorsa disponibile
accessibile e così via
se non sono anche in grado di
condividere questa mia visione con altri
difficilmente saremo in grado di
realizzarla ma soprattutto nel momento
in cui io sono capace di condividere la
mia idea di futuro con altre persone
la cosa più bella è che posso accogliere
in questa idea anche tutti i diversi
punti di vista di ognuno di noi un
futuro costruito in questo modo è in
grado
a quel punto di diventare anche un
futuro che possiamo chiamare preferibile
per la collettività
ed è proprio così che nella storia
dell'umanità sono avvenute vere e
proprie rivoluzioni
abbiamo iniziato a percepire la realtà
come qualcosa in più oltre rispetto al
presente
vedendo come se fosse una realtà
aumentata
tutti i possibili futuri che avevamo e
abbiamo di fronte a noi è come quando
vediamo insieme e magari da questo seme
riusciamo già immaginare tutte le
possibili piante che ne potrebbero
nascere farà dei fiori quanti fiori farà
farà dei frutti che gusta avranno questi
frutti dove spingerà le sue radici che
impatti avrà magari questa pianta sulle
piante che le stanno attorno
e così via ecco questa meravigliosa
capacità umana di guardare alla realtà
come qualcosa in più
e di conseguenza poi trasformare lo
status quo e ciò che noi chiamiamo
libertà
troppo spesso però ci dimentichiamo di
esercitarla e finiamo con l'adagiarsi di
fronte al presente e al futuro più
probabile che abbiamo di fronte a noi
dimenticando tutte quelle possibilità
che invece potremmo vedere se
adottassimo proprio quell atteggiamento
del chiederci è se invece tutte queste
scelte che abbiamo di fronte a noi nel
momento in cui adottiamo un
atteggiamento di questo tipo sono scelte
che vanno fatte insieme perché
vedete oggi abbiamo di fronte a noi la
possibilità di andare a cambiare
profondamente le radici di ciò che oggi
riteniamo essere l'essere umano e quando
io mi trovo a guardare la realtà con
questo atteggiamento
immagino tanti diversi possibili futuri
non posso non provare a confrontarmi non
posso non chiedermi se qualcuna di
queste possibilità sia migliore delle
altre e nel momento in cui faccio questo
esercizio
a quel punto non posso nemmeno evitare
la responsabilità di provare a fare
almeno quella che ritengo essere la
scelta più giusta
proviamo magari a esplorare insieme
qualche possibile futuro per farci
un'idea di come potrebbero andare le
cose
prendiamo ad esempio il campo delle
scienze della vita negli ultimi 20 anni
il costo per sequenziare un genoma è
sceso da più di 100 milioni di dollari a
poco più di mille siamo diventati molto
più bravi a capire cosa è racchiuso in
questi dati come usarli in alcuni casi
addirittura come modificarli di questo
passo con costi che scendono le nostre
abilità che aumentano ci troveremo
probabilmente di fronte a dei dilemmi
per i quali potremmo non essere
preparati
e allora prendiamo un futuro nel quale
vivono ad esempio elena e mauro elena
mauro sono una coppia e nel futuro in
cui vivono è considerato ovvio normale
intervenire su qualunque embrione prima
che arrivi ala sua nascita in quanto
coppia hanno deciso di diventare
genitori
in questo futuro vengono posti di fronte
a tutta una serie di scelte possono ad
esempio assicurarsi che nasca una
femmina coi capelli ricci castani
ma soprattutto possono anche assicurarsi
che abbia un'altissima probabilità di
diventare una grande atleta quando sarà
grande con quei parametri dovrebbero
fare queste scelte elena e mauro e se
invece elena e mauro vivessero in un
futuro nel quale questo tipo di analisi
rispetto all'embrione può essere fatto
solo a fini di salute e quindi magari
trovando un gene che potrebbe garantire
un'alta probabilità di una malattia
grave e dolorosa possono intervenire ed
assicurarsi che ne nasca un bambino o
una bambina sana ma tutto il resto non
conta
e sempre parlando di dna per esempio
invece andrea vive in un futuro nel
quale da questi dati è possibile anche
capire tante cose del proprio carattere
delle proprie attitudini
andrea appena ricevuto un'offerta di
lavoro da una delle società che paga di
più nel suo futuro in quelle in cui lui
vive questa società paga di più i suoi
dipendenti perché richiede loro di dare
libero accesso a tutti i dati del
proprio dna per creare i team migliori
da un lato qualche soldino in più
farebbe comodo ad andrea per potersi
permettere cure preventive che darebbero
maggiore salute e una maggiore longevità
però dall'altro lato ha saputo di
qualcuno a cui è stato negato un
avanzamento di carriera sulla base di
quei dati e ha paura che possa accadere
anche a lui
edito in questo caso delle scelte che
noi facciamo oggi nel presente
se proiettate con i loro effetti nel
futuro a lungo termine possono fare una
differenza enorme
infatti potremmo chiederci se invece
andrea vivesse in un futuro nel quale
questi dati non possono essere trattati
dai datori di lavoro ma solo da
istituzioni pubbliche ad esempio
trasparenti che garantiscono la privacy
del cittadino e che utilizzano quegli
stessi dati solo per rimetterli a
vantaggio della collettività e rendere
accessibili pure per migliorare la
salute di tutti i cittadini realtà
completamente diverse ma questo non vale
solo con riguardo al mondo della
genomica e del dna pensiamo anche a
tutte le nuove tecnologie ad esempio
lucia vive in un futuro nel quale ci
sono tantissimi robot dotati di
intelligenza artificiale
pensate fanno di tutto ci aiutano in
qualunque cosa si occupano della
sicurezza della città della casa dei
nostri appuntamenti cucinano fanno la
spesa lucia ha particolarmente bisogno
di un aiuto da quando una volta per
strada una sua espressione facciale è
stata male interpretata da un robot di
sicurezza il quale pensando che ci fosse
una situazione di pericolo ha deciso di
aprire il fuoco causandole una
disabilità
e se invece lucia vivesse in un futuro
nel quale da sempre si è deciso che mai
e poi mai un'arma possa essere dotata di
autonomia di intelligenza artificiale
nel quale queste nuove tecnologie che
possono garantirci maggiore sicurezza
sono comunque monitorate con buon senso
da un essere umano e quindi un incidente
di quel tipo non avrebbe causato nessun
danno a lucia semplicemente sarebbe
intervenuto qualcuno per decidere cosa
fare di fronte a quello che era
palesemente un errore i confini della
realtà e dei futuri che visiteremo né
verso i quali stiamo andando
sono definiti dalle scelte che facciamo
noi oggi rispetto a come vogliamo
gestire le grandi innovazioni del nostro
tempo
e così anche gli impatti che queste
innovazioni queste tecnologie avranno
sulle nostre vite
tutte queste sfide sono già racchiuse
nel seme del presente quel presente
aumentato che siamo in grado di vedere
solo se adottiamo quell'atteggiamento
del e se invece
e allora spesso quando si parla di
futuro
veniamo posti di fronte a visioni che
sono completamente distopiche dove tutto
andato storto la libertà è solo un
lontanissimo ricordo e addirittura la
specie umana ea rischio di estinzione
oppure qualcun altro ci racconta di
situazioni intoppi che dove non dovremo
più lavorare dove tutte le risorse
saranno abbondanti grazie alla scienza
la tecnologia vivremo più a lungo più
felici più sani
chi ha ragione la verità è che nessuna
di queste visioni può davvero
rappresentare la realtà
e sapete perché perché sono statiche
e la verità è che quando parliamo di
futuro parliamo di qualcosa che è sempre
in continuo cambiamento
e proprio perché in continuo cambiamento
richiede che ci sia da parte nostra un
monitoraggio costante
non possiamo navigare col pilota
automatico
in mezzo a una tempesta così come non
possiamo semplicemente adagiarci verso
un unico possibile futuro distrarci
lasciando che è semplicemente il futuro
accada è un crimine verso la nostra
libertà
e allora cosa possiamo fare direte voi
ma iniziamo da dall'immaginare
immaginare costantemente come potrebbero
andare le cose e cominciare ad adottare
questo atteggiamento chiederci è se
invece usando questo metodo in modo
costante facendolo diventare un
esercizio quotidiano allora sì potremmo
garantirci di avere di fronte a noi un
futuro che sia sempre aperto potremmo
assicurarci di difendere davvero la
nostra libertà
[Applauso]